on a video where I was talking about getting food stamps
someone decided to leave me this comment
if this doesn't scream I'm insecure
like what does
you have gotten to a point I would need this person
and everybody else to realise
like when you leave comments in somebody's video
I know that I'm a regular ass person in my house
just videos go viral cause they go viral
and I know that you're a regular ass person in your house
so you took the time in your night to sit there and this is
I mean you probably took up the whole
like limit of text
you felt the
and this is actually the part two of our comment
so this is going back and forth
if this is what you have to do to make yourself feel better
I seriously question the quality of your life and the happiness in your heart
because if you have a house
two cars a beautiful family
a good paying job
an amazing vinyl clinics collection
why are you on TikTok trolling me
why are you on TikTok challenging a woman at the food stands office
how you doing
how are you doing
you know what I mean
would you see me sitting there and just
you know bump it
no because that's ugly
you wouldn't do it in real life
but you do it on TikTok
because you're probably not as happy as you like to think
you know claim you are
so I hope you're doing okay
I hope you can like
see where you're at in life
realize maybe some things need to fucking change
and maybe make those changes
cause this is like